uh for mickey mouse audition by the way
how many how did you go in and say like
two lines no no no no that was so i i
think i'm not sure if i mentioned this
but i you know i passed on it at first
right right yeah yeah yeah but but it
was um we went to the old animation
building and i had to re-voice the
entire brave little tailor so it was all
the original original score and original
voices other than you know me going in
and doing waltz ah yes your honor and
how i was all alone i heard them coming
i looked up they were here there
everywhere a whole bunch of them yeah i
had to redo the whole thing and then
they
they re-voiced that old animation it's
one of the most exhilarating things i've
ever done holy you've got to do
some cool things yeah i i i got
a horseshoe i mean you portray robin
williams behind the camera which i have
to see now like how hard is that to
portray i mean he's so
physical so
so nuanced so all over the place i
remember my manager at the time called
and said so there's this and he's like
look these movies are sort of these
salacious
you know behind the scenes of three's
company or charlie's angels or whatever
it is he's like they're doing a mork and
mindy one
it's like a low budget thing they're
gonna shoot at vancouver in like 12 13
days or whatever it is but they need a
robin williams and they can't find it
and and i remember saying and my wife is
usually the one to sort of remind me why
i do what i do i was like
i was like i love robin williams i i
adore him but i'm not robin i don't look
anything like the guy i don't sound
anything like him and she said okay well
who would you cast i was like i don't
know like jim carrey or whatever i i i
would i wouldn't she said who would you
cast she said jim carrey's not going to
do a 500 000 movie who would you cast i
said i don't know she goes well if you
don't know then you should audition for
it
and and and i went on a deep dive i i i
i you know looked at all the inside the
actors studio stuff and i looked at all
this old stand up and there was some
stand-up tapes that my brother had my
older brother that were way too old for
me that i remember watching some of his
stuff in san francisco and uh and and i
realized that man i was a huge robin
williams fan i mean i i
i was really really
engaged in what he did
from stand up to all of his movies and i
remember when good will hunting came out
i had that on a loop on in my vhs i
watched it over and over and over and
over again so i guess a lot sort of
sort of by osmosis
sort of impacted how i i i was able to
sort of recreate that and i realized
when i was able to find his voice
and how he sort of held himself and how
he how he talked and
and sort of there was kind of a quiet
element to him and
and how he
he really didn't
he really didn't want the attention but
well he would take it i mean choke me if
you can't take a and there was this
this sort of jesus
you